during create equal not not this project
but critical uh we're up in san fran
you can hold your thought yep so as i
was in san francisco
with uh one of my assistants working on
create equal i just i wanted to do a
portrait of the hells angels
and you can't just like call them up i'm
some stranger from l.a i'm up but you
just you just have to show up
so nine in the morning i went to the
clubhouse in oakland for the hell's
angels
knocked on their door nobody answered
knocked on the door louder nobody
answered knocked on the door third time
what the [ __ ] do you want like this
biker shows up and he wants to kill me
because i woke him up and most people
will be like well
you don't want to do that but no i do
that i do that
but but i also know how to think on my
feet really really well better than
that's one of the things i've learned
it's like no i'll figure [ __ ] out
i don't know what i'm going to figure
out i don't know i'm not i don't i don't
even know what i'm going to have to
figure out
but whatever it is i'll figure it out do
you bring people with you when you do
this or do you do it alone i do it
like i'll have an assistant driving but
i don't want him involved i don't i'm
protecting him from getting hurt
right so he's off two blocks down there
you're unarmed
i never carry anything i've never shot a
gun no i'm not into that
um but people always say you should and
all that but well it's
it's hairy i'm 6'4 and i can kind of
take care of myself and
yeah even a biker hell's angel's not
going to i mean with
with a gun and a bat and a chain he
could probably do some damage but but
i i have a knack for
what's the word uh defusing i mean
right whatever if if somebody's got
something that they're threatening with
i have a way of showing them that look
i'm not a threat
i'm not here to hurt anybody right
here's what i'm doing like with the
pedophile as you said nobody said no to
me
because i presented to him away like
look i'm just looking to hear your story
i'm not here to make you look like a bad
guy i'm not here to do anything to you
i'm not here to do anything other than
hear your side of the story
and they can i think that i think people
can sense
somebody's up to no good or up or
there's something shady going on and i
don't do anything shady
like i'm not a liar i don't i don't do
things to people that
that i have to like i go to bed tonight
with a clear conscience every day of my
life
and that's super important to me because
like i'm not tricking anybody into
anything i'm not
scamming anybody i'm not pulling
anything i'm not pulling anything
i'm just telling you what i do if you're
interested that's cool and if you're not
that's cool too
yeah you're an open book i'm an open and
i'm not here to play anybody i'm not
here to
scam anybody so that's that's super
important and that
i think people can sense that and if
you're if you're just coming at people
with like you know here's here's what
i'm doing
i think you're interesting love to talk
to you love to hear your story
people love this to tell their stories
like i mean one of the things i find
interesting on my channel is
um a lot of these people have confessed
to like even murders
and crazy things there's there's a few
people that have confessed to
murders or things close to it things
that don't have a
statue of limitations on them so it's
like what why the hell would you say
that i'll say to them after the
interview like what
why the hell would you say that okay i'm
not worried about it
so you want me to put this on i can put
it on youtube you sure
and then yeah yeah go ahead